students may be singing songs from the
Broadway's smash-hit Hamilton as they
head back to school the musical was the
main attraction at many summer camps
across the country Nancy Cordes visited
with some so called Hamel kids to see
what they learned she is at the National
Portrait Gallery in Washington Nancy
your singing was very good we were into
playing you don't have to say that Jeff
I do I do enjoy it it's become a family
pastime and here at the Portrait Gallery
if this portrait in particular looks
familiar to you it's because it's the
one on the $10 bill but for most kids
they wouldn't have had much interest in
this man or in the time period until
recently until the musical Hamilton gave
them a soundtrack and a story that
brought the nation's founding to life
two years in it's still the hottest
ticket on Broadway but Hamilton is also
firing up young imaginations far from
New York City in places like Kansas City
Laguna Beach
and Chicago where the musical has kids
singing and dancing their way back in
time many of them have never seen the
show but they still know every word we
met middle schoolers Theresa Zack and
Catherine at imagination stage in
Bethesda Maryland where kids were
clamoring this summer for a spot in
Hamilton dance camp is all on the list
Hamilton danced and immediately I was
like mom I want to be in that camp on a
scale of one to ten how obsessed would
you say you are with Hamilton 11 I was
gonna say love it but I'd go more like
11 and a half I actually got my dad into
it and he actually started learning the
history of Alexander Hamilton's so we
like discuss it together push that
passion makes teaching to Hamilton a joy
and sometimes a challenge for dance
instructor Ashley MacKinnon as soon as
we finished one song for choreography
they immediately starts singing the next
song according to the soundtrack it's
like I said we're not there yet it's all
music to the ears of Hamilton creator
lin-manuel Miranda told CBS this morning
in 2016 that teaching history has become
part of the musicals core mission what's
exciting is we've got 20,000 students
coming to see this show over the course
of the next year and and one of the
things that's part of the curriculum
when they come to the show is they're
creating performance pieces based on
other histories incredible
Miranda started a program called edgy
Han with 13,000 kids in New York it will
reach more than 250,000 students over
the next five years December 19 1777 my
men lived in hail water nice in heaven
bringing an intensive Hamilton themed
history curriculum to kids all over the
country as the musical continues its US
tour I think Lynn Miranda and Hamilton
have presented us with an opportunity
that we must not lose historian Jim bass
helps oversee edgy ham the founding era
can seem to many students today like
castor oil take it it's good for you but
with the help of Hamilton our students
are finding it the most wonderful era to
dive into and to take ownership
themselves the only thing I knew about
Alexander Hamilton was that he was on
the back of the $10 middle that's all a
lot of people do in fact a lot of people
thought he was president yeah a case of
art illuminating life
my history teacher she had the common
sense book by Thomas Paine and then I
was like wait don't they mention that in
the song I had a reading common sense by
Thomas Paine
[Music]
[Music]
we found Hamilton themed camp programs
in at least a dozen states and many of
them told us that they're actually
planning to expand their offerings next
summer to meet public demand and based
on personal experience scale I can tell
you that the love that these kids
including the Quartus kids have for this
show doesn't appear to subside much over
time and we haven't even seen the show
yet I know that they're so amazing your
kids are really really cute dancing
that's what's so amazing even though the
kids haven't seen the play they love the
music and this makes them really want to
go
nicely done in cigarettes and the court
has kids